in 2020 tesla overtook toyota to become
the most valuable automotive maker in
the world tesla has long been hailed for
its innovative and sustainable approach
to design and manufacturing but what has
caused its value to suddenly skyrocket
to these new heights a major reason
behind tesla's rapid growth is the focus
that ceo elon musk has placed on
increasing productivity over the past
few years among the new operations
centers being launched by the company is
the 7 billion german mega factory giga
berlin the factory is slated to have
some surprising features such as a rave
cave and a swimming pool and is being
widely lauded as the next big step in
the global shift to electric cars so
let's take a deep look at the
multi-billion dollar factory and see
just what exactly will make giga berlin
so special tesla's major expansion
as of 2021 tesla's market value now
stands at a whopping 776
billion us dollars a far cry from the
billion dollar and 137 billion value of
toyota and volkswagen in second and
third place a major reason behind
tesla's rapid growth is the focus that
elon musk has placed on increasing
company productivity over the past few
years in 2019 musk opened giga shanghai
the first tesla factory outside of the
us and since then has announced four
more factories due to open around the
world by 2022 among these is the giga
berlin for which seven billion dollars
are being invested to establish the
first gigafactory in europe based in
berlin
musk casually dropped the announcement
of the mega factory's whereabouts during
his golden steering wheel acceptance
speech in berlin in 2019 the casual
announcement left the crowd stunned and
quickly generated equal parts hype and
intrigue as to what the new factory
would look like when questioned on his
reasoning for choosing berlin as tesla's
new european factory hub musk made his
fondness for the historic german capital
known saying i come to berlin a lot
before also adding that the city has the
best nightclubs jokes aside berlin has a
lot to offer when it comes to both the
automotive industry and tesla's
sustainable priorities germany has a
long established reputation for its
engineering and automotive manufacturing
being home to many of the world's most
reputable brands including mercedes-benz
audi volkswagen bmw and porsche however
several of these manufacturers have
fallen from favor in recent years due to
underperformance issues and scandals
involving their co2 emissions and
sustainability given its reputation for
world-class engineering and a population
that often ranks climate and
sustainability as its voter's top
concern it comes as no real surprise
that musk would choose berlin as the
base for his plans to revolutionize the
european car industry a seven billion
dollar mega factory so with seven
billion dollars currently being poured
into the project what can we expect the
new factory to look like well tesla
itself hasn't made too many official
comments on the project but they have
promised that gigafactory berlin
brandenburg will be the most advanced
high-volume electric vehicle production
plant in the world with such a promise
the factory is bound to boast an
impressive range of features in late
2020 elon musk was quoted as saying giga
berlin would almost certainly be the
world's most environmentally friendly
factory locally this will in part be
achieved by placing a major focus on
recycling both materials and energy the
factory is being designed so that the
excess heat generated by production will
be directly channeled and used to heat
the facilities come the colder months of
the year being designed with these kinds
of sustainable practices in mind is key
to musk living up to his major
environmental promises the plant is
intended to produce tesla batteries and
assemble the new model y once it is
publicly released in 2022. other
important components of tesla motors
such as the battery packs for their new
vehicles will be another valuable output
of the giga berlin facility beyond
manufacturing giga berlin is set to
function as a hub for sustainable energy
storage the factory is equipped with the
ability to store and harness both solar
and wind energy in order to promote the
use of sustainable power sources
focusing on sustainable energy usage
makes perfect sense given giga berlin's
location in the german province of
brandenburg as brandenburg has the
highest levels of sustainable energy
production per capita in the entire
country the state is home to over 3 700
wind turbines 35 000 solar plants and
over 500 biomass facilities and the wind
power industry alone already employs
about 7 000 people with such a green
infrastructure surrounding it the tesla
mega factory is set to fit right in with
its new neighbors more than just a
factory giga berlin is going to be home
to several production floors employing
upwards of 10 000 people as one would
expect from any super factory however
industry professionals and the public
alike have been raising their eyebrows
at some of the less conventional aspects
of giga berlin including plans for a
mega rave cave located right under the
factory it seems elon musk wasn't
messing around when he expressed his
love for the berlin nightlife to the
point where he himself wants to get in
on the action in march 2019 musk posted
a poll on twitter asking his followers
if tesla should have a mega rave cave
under the berlin gigafactory almost 800
000 people weighed in on the vote with
over 90 percent agreeing in a resounding
yes when the result of the vote became
clear musk enthusiastically added with
an epic sound system and woofers the
size of a car to the bill given berlin's
worldwide reputation for industrial
nightlife and mega raves it seems elon
musk knows exactly how to attract the
right kind of young and vibrant minds
he's looking for for his new tesla
venture in july 2020 as construction on
the facility officially began musk again
took to twitter to share images of the
factory's final rendering when followers
noticed a pool of water on the roof they
pressed the tesla ceo for clarification
when asked if this meant there would be
a swimming pool on the rooftop musk
responded briefly but clearly saying
sure changing the industry
the giga berlin factory is being
designed with the purpose of expediting
the shift to global electric car usage
and is supposed to serve as a new hub
for sustainable manufacturing in europe
tesla is clearly hoping to capitalize on
the recent push for greater climate
action in europe in the wake of
increasingly devastating droughts fires
and heat waves as well as the ongoing
action of the fridays for future climate
strikes the output expected to come from
the new mega facility is seriously
impressive with giga berlin being slated
as being able to produce up to 100
gigawatt hours per year to put things
into perspective one gigawatt of energy
can be enough to power between three
hundred thousand and seven hundred fifty
thousand homes depending on the time of
year on the production side of things
the plant is going to be home to some
major technological game changers giga
berlin is going to make use of the
gigapress the largest high pressure die
casting machines in the world the
gigapress is able to produce the entire
chassis of a car in a single casting
using high pressure molding and rapid
cooling this essentially means that
using the gigapress tesla can
manufacture their model y rear chassis
and crash rails as a single component
cutting down major assembly work in a
surefire bid to progress tesla's
productivity in the european market the
gigafactory berlin will manufacture
batteries battery packs powertrains and
seats with work including casting
stamping painting drivetrain assembly
and final assembly of model 3 model y
and future models with a yearly output
capacity eventually set to reach 500 000
cars tesla is currently aiming to
increase their production by 50 percent
a year and after upping their output by
over 40 in 2019 they seem to mean what
they say and are making this growth a
reality according to leaks from a
company white call musk again reiterated
his intention to continue with an annual
increase of 50 percent this would put
the company on track to achieve its
long-term goal of a million car output
capacity by the year 2030 completely
changing the face of the global
automobile industry a mega project in
order to handle such tall manufacturing
orders the gigafactory berlin is
situated on a three square kilometer or
0.4 square miles plot of land the site
was originally chartered for the
development of a bmw plant around the
year 2000 but the factory was ultimately
built in the neighboring german state of
saxony clearing the site for
construction required the removal of
pine forestry which local authorities
expect tesla to compensate for by
replanting a more diverse range of trees
and vegetation felling trees was far
from the most complex aspect of
beginning construction as engineers were
required to inspect and clear the site
of a range of unexploded bombs dating
back from wartime in total seven bombs
totaling 85 kilograms were detonated and
controlled explosions in order to make
way for the gigafactory talk about
opening with a bang getting the ball
rolling when it comes to getting a
project off the ground elon musk is
notoriously eager to see results
generally speaking this attitude
prevails the giga shanghai plant
launched production within a year of
being given the green light with
construction taking just 10 months after
first announcing giga berlin back in
2019 musk has had his sights firmly set
on beginning production by the end of
2021 but the notorious impassability of
german bureaucracy has caused a number
of setbacks still the mega company
remains hopeful to output to commerce by
the end of 2021. in preparation for this
milestone tesla chose october 2021 to
stage the gigafest a festival in which
local citizens and residents can come
check out the factory in its facilities
this is only adding to the major
excitement surrounding the new berlin
mega factory with tesla's giga berlin
set to revolutionize the european car
market and take the global automotive
industry one step closer to a green and
sustainable future